[Musique]
quand saint quentin en yvelines en fêtes
d'auros et la filiale française du
groupe de rock est un groupe
international suédois qui commercialise
en fait des produits de téléphonie
simplifiée pour les seniors sur saint
quentin dans con et que 19 dont
l'activité est essentiellement on va
dire tourner autour de la
commercialisation des produits
on avait déjà un accord de télétravail
avant d'être dans cette situation de
crise sanitaire du fait d'être un groupe
international on avait tous les outils
informatiques de connexion à distance
donc on a pu réagir très vite et mettre
en place le télétravail quasiment au
jour 1 du premier confinement nos
missions commerciales le permettent à
nos clients sont aussi très
majoritairement en télétravail
ça s'est très très bien passé au début
on sait bien organisés en plus on avait
envie qu'on est en télétravail complet
donc des petites réunions qu'on appelle
gardons le lien et qui permettait
effectivement d'être vraiment en lien
malgré tout le fait qu'on ait mis en
place sur ce deuxième confinement une
présence permanente
je vous expliquer les raisons pratiques
mais il y avait aussi des raisons un
petit peu plus parfois psychologique et
matériel pour des salariés dont les
conditions on va dire de logement
personnel de vie personnelle finalement
rendez le télétravail sur le long terme
assez pénible